how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel today we
have the full reveal of the Batsuit a
week or so ago we got the first teaser
of the Batsuit but it was really dark
and they didn't really reveal the full
suit kind of from the torso up and we
didn't even take a look at the cowl in
the bat ears and today not only do we
have some leaked photos of the full bat
suit in its entirety but we have a
leaked video as well of Batman on the
bat bike so let's start with the video
[Music]
now as you can see in this video it's
very clear that this is the bat bike and
the Batman is in full costume as well
and according to the people that were on
the set filming he was not supposed to
fall it's just raining and very slippery
and the stunt double just fell now there
is a woman riding a bike next to him
which is widely believed to be Catwoman
although she never takes her helmet off
when we don't get a good look at her but
if we take a look at some of these still
photos of Batman we get a really good
look at the bat suit including his ears
now keep in mind this isn't Robert
Pattinson in the bat suit it's his stunt
double filming scenes but this is what
the bat suit is going to look like for
the most part it's going to be a little
bit more slender because they obviously
have to put padding in this for the
stunt double but this actually kind of
looks like the Batman year one suit as
you can see he has a lot on his utility
belt he even has some other utility
straps and pockets on his legs he's got
very pointy and thin ears and he also
has these things that are on his
forearms now these could be weapons or
they could be some type of hydraulic
system to make him stronger and if you
look under them you can clearly see the
blades so this bat suit looks to be
decked out with just a lot of tactical
tools it looks to be pretty well armored
as well we can see the armor on his
shoulders the chest plate is pretty big
but it still looks pretty versatile and
flexible it's not super huge and chunky
like the one that ben affleck had and
batman vs superman what's interesting to
note about these photos is that it's
daylight and he's outside and he looks
to be at a graveyard perhaps visiting
the graves of his parents now we've
learned that the batman is going to take
place during Bruce Wayne's second year
as the Batman so it is likely that at
some point in time we're going to see
him return to his parents grave which
could
this scene that we're seeing right here
I definitely don't think that this could
be the only bat suit that he wears I
actually think this is a very specific
suit probably meant to ride the bat bike
specifically because there's really no
armor on his legs and I think the full
bat suit most likely will have that this
is most likely just meant for riding a
bike but there you have it our first
look at hopefully only one of the bat
suits that Robert Pattinson will wear in
the Batman again keep in mind this is
for his stunt double and the real suit
will look probably a little bit more
slender but let me know what you think
about this do you like the look that
they're going for do you like that it
kind of looks like your one or what else
do you think about it let me know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe but notifications turned on to
stay up to date on everything relating
to the Batman the DC Universe and of
course Marvel and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching we'll fall off